today we're gonna be working out an area
now this is what we call an irregular
area because the shape of it is not
really a nice rectangle or a nice square
or a nice circle it's just kind of this
weird looking shape here slightly I'm a
polygon it's got curvy edges and
straight edges over here so how do we
approach this thing you can see I've
outlined this shape and all the
information in between about trees and
this basketball court and the paths and
so on well we can factor that in later
we're just going to consider this first
big outline shape and work out its area
so if I just consider the the actual
shape itself this is what we've got now
we did approach this as in our first
case as a set of our composite shapes
put together okay so you could divide
this up however you like you can see
there's like a big rectangle and fin
here and you can put different spaces
around here now keeping in mind that
we're going to be estimating this it's
not going to be exactly correct we don't
have to have every single little nook
and cranny calculated
the simpler we can make this for us the
better so what I've done is I've put
together this set of composite shapes
you can see that all I've got really is
three rectangles I've got one big
rectangle here I've got a smaller
rectangle and another smaller rectangle
and that's here you might say man that's
terribly inaccurate you know I'm missing
heaps of pieces on this and that's kind
of true but if you have a look say for
instance this are rectangle over here
you can see that this rectangle is
bigger than the area that I'm trying to
calculate it's got these extra spots
over here but at the same time what I've
got is other spaces within the area that
I haven't calculated so I'm kind of
estimating and making these extra bits
try to balance with the bits that I'm
missing it's a little bit like the trick
you can do if you're adding a bunch of
numbers for instance I'll just put this
down here if I said please add 47 14
plus 47 plus 12 okay well I could just
actually do all the numbers on these and
do it exactly I'll punch it into a
calculator but I can say this is going
to be approximately equal to and I can
round all of these numbers and see what
I get
so 14 would round to 10
37 were drowned 250 and 12 would also
round to 10 so this is going to be
approximately equal to 10 plus 50 plus
10 which is 70 okay now if you actually
go ahead and check what this is equal to
14 plus 12 is going to be 26 and when
you add that to 47 I think you're going
to get 73 so clearly I'm in the ballpark
I've got something that's roughly right
and I can use this approach of you know
sometimes rounding numbers up and
sometimes rounding numbers down and
everything should sort of come out in
the wash and I'll have a reasonably
close answer so what I've done is in
order to work out the areas of these
rectangles clearly I'm gonna need some
measurements okay
so I've taken my sent my my ruler and
I've done this all in centimeters these
are the numbers that I've gotten now you
can see here I've got my my long edge of
this big rectangle here 14.9 and it's
corresponding breadth is eight point
four and then I've done all the other
measurements okay now we know how to do
the areas of rectangles they're really
really easy all you have to do is length
times breath then you do length times
width again lengths songs but again and
you'll have three areas I've just put
together a quick table that shows you
what happens when you go lengths by
Brett that gives you one rectangle
another rectangle and this is the
biggest rectangle here and this is what
they add up to okay now it's worth
mentioning all of these lengths here
right these are all centimeters and um
so these which means that these over
here are centimeters squared centimeters
squared
now we know who that the area we're
doing is not centimeters squared it's
going to be meter square it's a much
bigger area so what I need to do is I
need to work out a scale I need to work
out well what is um one of these meant
to correspond to in real life so I'm
going to come back to my diagram what
I've got in here if I if I come back to
the original is that I went and I took
this satellite photo and I measured from
here to here with my ruler okay now the
length of that I ended up calculating
measuring yeah was well let's see here
I'm gonna be going over here I might use
this okay so when I place this ruler
across I measure sixteen point seven
centimeters okay all the way from here
up to here sixteen point seven
centimeters now I can use my satellite
photo to find out what that measurement
is in meters and what I find is
according to the satellite photography
that my sixteen point seven centimeters
is supposed to be equivalent to a
hundred and five point six three meters
okay so in order to work out translate
this into meters squared I want to know
what one centimeter is so if I divide
both sides by a sixteen point seven what
you'll end up getting is about six point
three three meters now there's a tricky
thing here because this is a this is a
length and I'm interested in an area so
it would be an easy thing to say oh okay
therefore one square centimeters since
when
centimeter will be six point three three
square meters but that's actually not
quite right because one square
centimeter I'll just put this over here
we write it like that what it really
means is a literally a square with one
centimeter over here and one centimeter
over here one by one and so it's really
one centimeter times one centimeter and
that's why the ones come together and
the the CM the mid the units come
together you get two of those okay but
this key is that it's a square right
it's a square it's one centimeter by 1
centimeter so if I had a square like
this one centimeter by 1 centimeter then
it should be equivalent to a square
that's got these dimensions instead it
should be six point three three meters
times six point three three meters
that's a bit sneaky isn't it one square
centimeter is not six point three three
square meters one square centimeter
is in fact if you crunch the numbers I
got forty meters
squared give or take okay it's this is
this is roughly equivalent okay
so this is great I can take this value
here and I can multiply it by 40 and if
I just reach from my calculator now I'm
going to get one five one point two
seven times forty so I'm getting an
estimated area of about six thousand
square meters okay so this is one add
site that we've got and the method we
used was composite areas so the first
approach was to break this shape this we
don't compress a figure into many
different sort of like a rectangle and
another rectangle and another rectangle
or whatever other shapes you would like
to combine but the other way we're going
to do is using Simpsons rule so since
this rule approximates this in another
way and it uses a different formula now
the approach is going to be quite
different we're going to need to divide
up the shape across a diagonal and by
the way it doesn't have to be this
diagonal it could be like another day
over here or any other diagonal you like
and then across that diagonal we're
going to break up this shape with some
lines that cut the diagonal across and
divide up the entire area into a bunch
of shapes that we can then compare so
I've already done this and then what you
do is with this shape is you need some
measurements okay now before we do the
measurements and put them on there one
thing you should know is that these
lines they're not random okay these
three lines that go across for starters
you can probably see they're all
perpendicular to our diagonal there okay
the diagonal is really important because
everything kind of branches off off of
that this diagonal not only is a
perpendicular to all of these but the
diagonal is broken up into chunks one
two three four that are all equal to
each other and because you can see the
way I've drawn up these kinds of
distances it's kind of like a height so
this distance which is the same as all
of the other ones we call the height or
we can call it H okay so we're going to
refer to that distance I've already done
all of my measurements so I actually
know that for
the height it's equal to for example
this one yeah just to make it easier to
read is 4.4 centimeters you've also got
this distance across here which is seven
point three centimeters this distance
across the middle nine point eight
centimeters and this last one the
longest one is twelve point one okay now
what do I do with all of these pieces
I'm going to need to throw them into
this special formula that's Simpsons
rule and the formula for Simpsons rule
goes like this it starts with that
height that we were talking about which
we'd measured as four point four
centimeters the area is approximately
equal to that height divided by three
times and I'll explain this part in a
second you've got the first width across
you've got four times the middle width
and then you've got the last width okay
so when I'm talking about widths what I
mean is on the diagram you can see
you've got the heights going this way
and you've got the widths going this way
okay
now you can see this requires three
widths and I've got a whole bunch more
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna divide
this into two pieces I'm going to take
this part here so if you like it's going
to be this area and I'm going to work
that out so you can see there's a first
value at first with which in fact it is
zero I've got a second width across
there and a third width and then I'm
gonna work out this area up here and a
separate piece so I'll put some dots on
that so this area up here
I'm also going to have a first width a
middle width and a last with so we'll
call this one over here a 1 and we call
this a tune we can work them out in
order okay let's give this a go a 1 it's
approximately equal to and my height is
about 4 point 4 divided by 3 and then we
want to punch in these three numbers
that correspond to the widths here right
so the first way first width I mentioned
is zero because I'm kind of starting at
this at this point yeah
plus 4 times the middle width which is 7
point 3 plus the last width which is 9
point 8 okay now when you throw this
into your calculator what you'll find is
you'll get 57.2 and I'm doing this in
square centimeters at the moment I'm
gonna repeat the process for the top
area up here a two okay
the height is the same it's still 4
point 4 divided by 3 but my first middle
and last are now completely different
numbers this is first then middle and
then last so I'm gonna have 9 point 8
plus 4 lots of 12.1 plus the last one
which is zero because again just like I
started I'll end at a point up there
which is width like that where there is
actually zero okay again punch that in
and the number I calculated was eighty
five point three six centimeters so
therefore when I total these up what I'm
getting is a hundred and forty two point
five six centimeters squared just like
before um this is not you know this is
not the actual size I'm gonna be in
meters squared I'm gonna multiply by 40
right so when you do that you're getting
approximately 5,700 square meters okay
which you can see is in the same
ballpark as what we worked out before
and they're not the same because we've
used a completely different method to
get these answers but at least we know
our our responses are sort of similar
where do we're on the right track here
okay now one of the great things about
Simpsons rule even though it looks a lot
more complicated is that it's a lot
easier to increase the level of accuracy
you've got if we went back to
this shape over here the way that we
would increase the accuracy of this is
we would consider smaller and smaller
shapes so for instance I could have done
this this triangle over here I could
have chucked in another rectangle maybe
another rectangle in there and so on and
the more I've got the more accurate my
shape will become and the more accurate
my area will become now I can do a
similar kind of trick with Simpsons rule
what I'm going to do is I still got the
same diagonal but instead of having one
two three widths measured across I'm
going to add more so I've already done
the measurements on this one you can see
I've got my original three here one two
three that I've highlighted but then I'm
adding a whole bunch more in fact I've
got twice as many so instead of my
height being four point four this
distance here my height is now two point
two so this is substantially smaller
each of these chunks is going to be more
accurate because you can see just like
with the competent figure I'm dividing
it up and when you go through the same
process like this but you're going to go
through it many more times what you'll
find is that it's from the total area in
square centimeters it comes out soon I
believe it's a hundred and fifty two
point five three three that's in
centimeters squared
so when I work out my actual area which
is multiplied by 40 I'm going to get 150
to three three times forty so I'm
looking at six 101.3 two meters squared
now 6100 so this is great because we can
see that all of the answers that we've
got were in the same ballpark but we can
get more accuracy as we need it right
now I guess our last step from here is
then to consider well all we've worked
out is just this big outline shape right
this this figure in pink but there's a
basketball courts removed this
particular picture is not going to be
very useful to golf because this
basketball courts have been up they've
been changed since this satellite
photography was taken we've also got
paths happening in here and also if we
if we went up to the site we can see
that some of these areas they're covered
in benches and other kinds of things
which really
be taken away from our final figure but
all of these are methods you can use to
with quite decent accuracy calculate an
irregular area